من الرائع أن أراكم ، لقد
قلت إنك تريد بشدة أن
تتأكد من أنك تتخذ القرار الصحيح في
نهاية المطاف مدى
صعوبة قرار البقاء هنا ، كان
القرار الأصعب في حياتي لأكون صادقًا
في حياتي المهنية بالتأكيد
لأنني أريد ذلك  أردت أن أتخذ أفضل
قرار تعرفه لم أكن أريده أن يكون
خاطئًا وهذا يستغرق وقتًا لأن
عليك التفكير في كل الأشياء
التي يجب عليك أن ترى كل الأشياء التي يمكنك
القيام بها هناك
ولكني أعتقد أنني اتخذت  القرار الصحيح
لأنه قراري ،
ما الذي حدث في نهاية
الأسبوع الماضي الأسبوع الماضي ، كانت هذه هي اللحظة الأخيرة
عندما أقول حسنًا ، لقد تم ذلك ،
سأبقى في psg um
لأنه كان من دواعي سروري أن أقول
شكراً لجميع اللاعبين في  فرنسا لأنني
فرنسي لأقول شكراً لـ PSG
للجماهير لجميع الناس ،
شكرًا لك على السنوات الخمس وأعتقد أن
هذا العقد الجديد يشبه حسنًا ، شكرًا
لك ، سأبقى وأريد أن أعطي
ثديي تجاه  تاريخ النادي
وبلدي وهناك  هناك الكثير من التقارير التي
تحدثت بها إلى الرئيس ماكرون ، لقد كان
جزءًا لا يتجزأ من القرار ، نعم أتحدث
معه كثيرًا.
أتحدث مع الكثير من الأشخاص ، الكثير من
الأشخاص المهمين الذين لم أتخيلهم أبدًا في
حياتي سأتحدث معهم  هؤلاء الناس
من مستقبلي ،
لكن نعم نتحدث كثيرًا ، لقد قدم لي نصيحة جيدة ،
لكن
مع كل الاحترام الذي أكنه له ،
كان قراري أن أتخذ هذه النصيحة
بعد أن أتخذ قراري ، هل يمكنني أن أسأل عما
قاله لك وما قاله لك  كان
يريدني أن أبقى هنا
بهذه البساطة
لأنه أرادني أن أبقى هنا ولكن بعد أن
أخبرني الكثير من الأشياء ولكن
لاستئنافها كان نعم أريدك أن تبقى
في البلد